you know what time it is tool time as
appropriate there's a lot of people who
are tools in Hollywood
no hi my name is grace Helbig no no your
name like it's different now if this is
your first grace Helbig red carpet
fashion review welcome you're gonna love
it or hate it
there's hardly any in between and if
you're not new that means that you love
it that's what I tell myself you
couldn't possibly just hate watch me
Emmys they happen so let's review the
red carpet fashion caveat as always I
will mispronounce names I won't likely
not review someone you wanted me to or
someone you didn't want me to deal with
it and I'm sorry I shouldn't have to say
I'm sorry but I'm one of those people
that says they're sorry even if you run
me over with your car I'll be like I was
on the sidewalk my fault Tracee Ellis
Ross oh she can do no wrong she brought
the entire roll of crepe paper with her
to the Emmys this year yeah this is like
a half inflated Macy's Day princess
peach balloon and I love it
Tracy Ross can pull off things like this
if I tried to do this it would be
problematic people would be bothered
uncomfortable triggered this does
nothing but inspire I love it kiddo I
know we have a lot of people to get to
oh my god natasha Lyonne she always
looks like she just your brother I
admire how confident she is so hard
that's not a good thing to put so hard
and your brother doesn't matter sex
doily cute Fred Armisen
is he wearing vampire teeth quirky
grills had their time vampire teeth go
for it and if those aren't vampire teeth
it's you had an accident I'm sorry
either way you can pull it off cute Yara
Shahidi ah another person that can do no
wrong you know the team that alien comes
out of that person's chest in that movie
this is like the very romantic Martha
Stewart version of that cute Alison Brie
ooh she's a real it girl what happens
when you take the it girl out of uncle
Joey's favorite phrase you got cut out
that was too long of a walk for nope
but you look great slits and cuts
everywhere it's like you got attacked by
a very stylish pair of scissors cute
Samantha beep whoo like a tease business
Ursula
goes to an award show cute Sarah
Silverman whoa this is like a very
fashionable quinceanera party and the
theme was funeral cue Darren Criss what
are you wearing Flynn what this kind of
looks like fashion statement and I'm so
into this cute
Evan Rachel Wood wit are you wearing it
went pants like if Lane Bryant the store
was a woman but then she had like kind
of Wow child younger sister that was a
store and sold clothes they would sell
like this kind of stuff cute nicely
Jones
Oh getting in on that hologram a
hologram woman's pantsuit
this is Internet this is political this
is fashion this is comfortable she has
all audiences covered with this outfit
if she's got slime in her pockets you
laura dern Oh what why this outfit has
multiple identities to it this is like
Paula Abdul and sandy Dee and Game of
Thrones all got together and made a
garment dude Ozzy beats whoa this is
cool this is like Renaissance and Game
of Thrones and also space future but
just overall queen I tired
I feel intimidated by this outfit it
makes me have highs so that's great Kiyo
Sara Bareilles another one that went for
the navy blue I love it this is really
classic and pretty and also a fabric
like that silk is impossible to keep
completely wrinkle free if you're
traveling in a limo or I already got
that car or like one of those bird
scooters
you didn't have this wrinkle-free on you
that's very impressive my age is showing
just because I've stopped caring so much
about fashion and just about how they
got there without the wrinkles cute
Sarah Paulson I love Sarah Paulson Wow
it's very sleek and modern fashion on
top and like you let your pubes grow out
for years on the bottom and I support
both of those things cute Chrissy Teigen
yes girl this is like John from Mad Men
meets
Jane from the Jetsons and I love it cute
Milly Bobby Brown walks on your dress Oh
little flowers this is very fashionable
but you still get to be demure and
age-appropriate but still be like no one
your age that goes to regular school
will ever get a chance to wear a dress
like this also I love a big billowing
bottom there's more to the sentence of a
dress because it gives you a parameter
in which no one can infiltrate when
you're at social events so she's being
very smart with this choice cute Bobby
from queer I you look like Frank Sinatra
cute and France you know what you're
doing I don't even need to review you
because it would be a waste you know
what you're doing cute Anthony did you
just come from like the sex version of
the Ringling Brothers Barnum & Bailey
Circus cuz you're quite the ringmaster
yeah Jonathan Van Ness yes yes a white
power pantsuit with are you wearing a
plastic shirt are you like sweating out
toxins while serving high-fashion while
holding like a medieval coin purse I
said yes to all of this cute Khurram oh
you guys they're all just playing game
to try to one-up each other with their
fashion now that's all they're doing are
you the next Doctor on Doctor Who
tonight subscribe to that cute Keri
Russell ooh
sex pigeons cute Rachel Brosnahan
I think I saw you saying last name I
don't know I'm sure I said it wrong
remember my caveats this looks very
pretty very drapey Oh should I tell her
that you're like Stratus down-up no it's
supposed to be that way it's a great
conversation starter and you don't have
to shave any of our
hair under this arm because you can't
get that up there why bother
cute Tiffany Haddish I love Tiffany
Haddish I love it bright fun a perfect
reuse of those parachutes that they may
display within gym class in elementary
school Jessica Biel another person
that's absolutely fantastic this looks
like a weird assure painting and I can't
tell if you're right in front of the
camera or really far away from it but
cute Wendell and Christy I love this
anytime you can trick someone into
thinking they the Rope you're wearing on
a red carpet is fashion I am so down for
it cute Mandy Moore always looks
fantastic you look sweet as candy like
pre-chewed licorice candy but like sexy
pre-chewed licorice candy very sleek
cute Tina Fey ooh very boudoir meets um
belt yeah Jennifer Lewis this is
actually fantastic and this is all I've
ever wanted is someone to carve the way
her athleisure to be accepted at
red-carpet events I love this cute Heidi
Klum she's there I was worried and
everything's okay everyone calm down
no one freaked out everyone calm the
sound Heidi Klum's at the Emmys 2018 the
world has the possibility to be okay she
looks great it's like she sprinted to
Macy's Labor Day Sun got 60% off some
sweet-ass silk sheets and yeah she made
a dress out of it cute
okay oh my gosh guys I'm sorry I have to
stop there there's so many people and
obviously I missed a lot of people that
I'm sure you wanted me to talk about or
I'm sure you wish they would have shut
up a long time ago but there you go
there is my yellow carpet is it yellow
beige dirty office carpet and these
fashion review if you like to give a
thumbs up let me know down the comments
below who is your favorite or least on
the pistil carpet and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
post some videos here and there what
does and click that bug notification so
you'll know other than that I don't know
woo okay Ric Flair whoa Megan Mullaly
always looks fantastic this is very a
rose by any other name would probably
end up bringing Leonardo DiCaprio's
character back in the Titanic that Rose
if she was named like Deb Deb's on
letting go of Jack no Deb needs Jack
Jack makes dad look cool this got wildly
off track cute